you were featured in Pink's beautiful
trauma how's pink
she was incredible so I played pink in
her video beautiful trauma and she I
didn't get the chance to meet her we
were like over face time and it was very
cool to be able to collaborate with her
she was I think on tour at the time so
she was like helping us film this video
and she's overseas doing her thing and
being amazing and the choreographers RJ
and Nick were you know extremely
talented they had this vision and it was
a very cool part to play it was like
back in like the 60s and she's like
beautiful and the trauma and kind of
talk about like Perfection and all these
things yeah kind of that's where I began
to start loving you know acting was
through dance and all these things any
you know anytime I'm able to like
perform and entertain people it's that's
where I like Thrive starting so young
entertaining and dance getting thrown up
on a stage dancing for X Factor in it
being live and having to nail all of
your nervous so nervous and like having
to nail your choreo realizing like this
is live girl also like did you mess up
at all no thank God because that would
have been really bad you know
do you ever mess up yes okay because
yeah you're gonna do a lot more of that
yes we all mess up 100 you know how to
deal with you're like okay I messed up
yes yes you can't get down you have to
just keep going you're getting more
takes exactly yeah
no you go no but that's what's very
interesting when I began acting and talk
about like self tapes now that being so
big being in the room it was very much
like it was like one shot and that was
it then one like I kind of went from
this dance into from what I've been
taught at such a young age everything
being perfect because in dance there is
no you obviously you're gonna mess up
like you're gonna get in trouble by your
choreographer it's gonna be a big ordeal
like messing up is not allowed so when I
got into acting
I'd get a script and I thought
everything had to be perfect so like my
dog or somebody would bark or the door
would open and I'd hear like a Creak and
I'm like oh I gotta redo it yes I'd be
like I gotta redo it I don't and now I'm
like no those this is like what happens
in life this is real so if my dog barks
and I can play with it then I'm gonna go
ahead and and make it work but like it's
very interesting coming from that
perfectionism and dance and realizing
like let that all go into acting you
know it's very
very interesting I did a self tape yeah
not too long ago it's one of the few
self tapes I've done in recent history
in recent times
um and I was doing it and I had somebody
reading with me and my friend Deneen
she had a couple drinks
from some soccer thing that they were
watching and they came back to my house
and we're hanging out we're gonna order
some food
and she was in the uh in the kitchen she
knew I was doing the tape
and in my audition tape I thought it was
so good that I'm not doing another tag
and you could hear her go ma and
immediately here
Tom told her to shush her boyfriend
because she was about to start talking
she goes uh English
and you hear and I go no
it was a comedy at least so let him
laugh let him go what the hell was that
it was loud and I was like you know
tough [__] I'm not doing it again oh my
guess what you booked it no I didn't
yeah
did not get the part but you know the
reason it was it was it was funny
because when I read it I go They're
gonna go for like a
a big dude like uh Ethan Supply like a
you know big strong bearded kind of guy
who could be a coach of a team and I was
like I go um I don't know I could be I
just said I'm gonna try because I like
it yeah I tried it and they said yeah I
just we just want a bigger guy and a
that's in our mind I'm like fine